welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss in the star wars spin-off series
the bad batch was one of the biggest
reveals at the disney investor day last
week
a spin-off following clone force 99 from
the clone wars that according to this
new trailer appear to be connecting the
dots between
revenge of the sith and clone wars 2 the
mandalorian rebels rogue one
a new hope maybe even a live-action
kenobi series there is
a lot of star wars news to unpack i'm
going to start by breaking down this bad
batch trailer for all the interesting
details and star wars connections that
you need to
know let's do it here we go
they call themselves the bad batch the
trailer opens with the voice of
commander cody you remember him he's the
one who fired on obi-wan kenobi on udapa
this is actually the same audio from
when he introduced the bad batch back in
season seven of clone wars earlier this
year experimental unit clone force
99 the defective clones with the
desirable mutations they call themselves
the bad batch clone force 99 aka the bad
batch are a group of defected clone
troopers each having a unique skill that
makes them an elite soldier but they are
not that great at following the rules
which with order 66 coming i think we
can assume is a good thing they are led
by hunter who's great with that knife
crosshair a sharpshooter
tech he does machines and wrecker a big
strong dumbass they also have a new
fifth member ekko
whom they rescued in that recent bad
batch arc of clone wars he was a clone
originally part of rex's crew previously
thought to be
dead for seasons and seasons but all
that time was actually held by
separatists with his brain being mined
for republic strategy secrets
and after they rescued him he decided
hey i'm gonna go with this bad match
because i'm broken now in the trailer we
see them arriving
at that cloning facility on camino you
remember that from attack of the clones
we also see them entering
the training room in the clone wars
series that's kind of where it all
begins for all clone troopers
so the big question of this series will
be will this bad batch participate in
order 66 are they gonna turn on the jedi
is echo gonna do that
i am thinking no because first yes we
have to like them
but really because these are genetic
defects the cloners might not even put
the inhibitor chips in their heads that
they gave all the other clone troopers
and palpatine needs those inhibitor
chips in order to switch them evil for
order 66. now ekko
was given a chip like that however all
the tinkering the separatists probably
did on him
might have disabled that ship or at
least disabled it just enough for him to
resist that order when it comes just as
rex was able to resist it maybe be able
to consciously alert the rest of the bad
batch about what the hell is going on
also see how this trailer does show
quite a bit of conflict between the bad
batch and the rest of the clone troopers
i think that's gonna be the main
conflict of this series how these
rejects have to forge their own destiny
when the side they've been fighting for
just loses it this opening clip also
shows a few planets that i think are
familiar places
this brownish colored one i'm pretty
sure is kessel because notice those
three moons behind it i think those are
kessel's three moons
castle home of the spice mines and the
famous kessel run and then there's a
blue planet with a stormy atmosphere
and an industrial sector i'm hoping this
could be iudu because i have a feeling
this bad batch series is going to
explore the origins of what we saw in
rogue one
project stardust galen erso and director
krennic and then there's the slaver
planet zygeria which we have seen before
after order 66 actually admiral wolfe
gallaran was deployed to
invade zygeria and we know the empire
used zygeria's slavers to
continue the practice of slavery
including enslaving the wookiees and
then we see the bad batch on a jungle
planet with vegetation that looks a lot
like felucia
where ayla sakura was gunned down on
order 66. i think this show is gonna tie
in a lot of the aftermath of that for
the first time we're gonna
see what the early years of the empire
looked like it's very exciting
and very scary here hunter fights uh
zigerian slaver and then a later shot of
hunter out of armor on a speeder headed
towards someone you can see
dangling from a tower there i think the
series after everything goes down is
gonna follow the bad batch
having defected from the empire taking
off their armor and then living on as
mercenaries taking odd jobs like this
and then there's a shot where they
approach this orange streaked planet i
think these are the rusty scrapyards of
braca and we'll see closer looks of
these later in the trailer okay so the
bat batch lines up with other clone
troopers as they listen to
emperor palpatine's big speech that we
saw in revenge of the sith you remember
when democracy died to thunderous
applause
will be reorganized into the first
galactic empire
now if you look at the timeline this
speech took place after order 66 went
out and the jedi purge began
so i think the bad batch might have
sidestepped those orders and then no one
knew about it then they hear this speech
and then later when they return to
camino the truth comes out and it causes
their conflict with their clone brothers
and that would lead to the shots we've
seen of hunter and the rest lining up in
arms against the armed clone troopers
though
notice how one of those has darker armor
with this cool green visor he carries a
flamethrower
these badasses show up a few times in
the trailer i am wondering if these are
covert ops clone troopers these are the
guys who call in to do the dirty work
the jobs no one else wants to do
in this case it might be to lead the
hunt for the bad batch
a task typical clone troopers might have
trouble carrying it out
but before we continue i want to thank
our friends at magic spoon for helping
sponsor this episode
see while being stuck at home this year
my eating habits have not been great
i've been trying to cut down on the
sugar and unhealthy food but papa still
needs his comfort food well luckily for
me
there's magic spoon cereal it is the
tasty cereal of our childhoods without
all the
junk in it each serving of this stuff is
only 110 calories it has
zero sugar 11 grams of protein and only
three net grams of carbs it's keto
friendly gluten free grain grain-free
soy-free low-carb
and gmo free i am currently trying out
the peanut butter flavor
it's so good this is like the best
peanut butter cereal i've ever had but
like again it's not gonna make me feel
like
afterwards you know but they got a ton
of great flavors including the original
cocoa fruity frosted and blueberry
flavors but also brand new ones like
peanut butter cinnamon it's all really
really good folks click the link below
to get some magic spoon
cereal today you can build your very own
variety box and use my code new
rockstars for free shipping
you can choose from the best-selling
cocoa fruity frosted and blueberry
flavors plus
brand new flavors that just dropped
including peanut butter and cinnamon
so many of you have asked and now is the
first time magic spoon has ever released
this new option to build your very own
custom box with new flavors to choose
from so don't wait and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it is back
with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they will refund your
money
no questions asked so click the link
below and use the code new rockstars for
free shipping
or go to magicspoon.com new rockstars
and before i move on yeah we see the
scrap yard
and that looks like a wrecked venator
class star destroyer i think yeah this
could be bronco which does set the stage
for an interesting possible crossing
paths with a
young cow kestus from jedi fallen order
okay this section reveals
freaking fennec shand the masks bounty
hunter that we have been seeing a lot of
on the mandalorian this season it's so
cool to see her take part in this
because in the most recent episode we
just heard her say no i'm wanted by the
isp
and presumably we're gonna see the
reasons she is on the imperial security
bureau's bad side
particularly helping with the revolt on
kamino
it's also possible that she could tie
into boba fett's unfinished clone wars
episodes and we might see boba fett on
the show maybe we'll finally find out
how those two bounty hunters knew each
other prior to their time together years
later on the mandalorian the bad batch
also
fight these heavily armored droids which
do look a lot like the dark troopers
we've been seeing on the mandalorian as
well except now they have this white
armor so it might be somewhere between a
phase two and phase three or there's
like a phase three b
i think and we could be seeing the early
years of imperial attempts to replace
human warriors with droids a plane that
moth gideon later picks up
and i guess a plane that kind of would
bring it full circle with the
separatists originally using battle
droids and the clone wars ah it's like
poetry it rhymes you know how it is
okay and this clip is a battle in which
you can see the republic att is blowing
up
a droid tank meaning at least some of
this series will show us before order 66
when the clone wars were still in their
closing days
this looks a bit like the battle of
kashyyyk and the bad batch were thought
to have gone to kashyyyk in the final
days of the clone wars but the other big
reveal of this trailer is
tarkin but notice his imperial officer
badge is still the rank of
admiral here he's not yet grand moff
tarkin as he isn't a new hope in rogue
one with tarkin i hope
again we get to explore his relationship
and rivalry with director krennic
that would set the stage for rogue one
interesting here to see the imperial
troopers being cheered on by regular
folks because
yes in the early days of the empire the
masses would have embraced them as war
heroes to
thunderous applause and then a shot of
this scary looking super laser wow
now yes we are years away from the
empire constructing
a successful wmd super laser but we
could be looking at the early test
stages in
project stardust this could also be
connected to the mystery of how anaxis
was blown up after clone wars to create
that asteroid field which became in
rebels what happened there there's a
mystery they're gonna dig into it maybe
it just took him a couple tries of
firing a superlaser and they tested it
on an axis and the final title is
revealed by burning away the clone wars
into the bad batch
suggesting that though the clone wars
may be finished behind that war fought
on false pretenses
is a band of authentic freaks just
trying to survive the crossfire and yeah
there is a lot that we're gonna dig into
between hayden christensen being
confirmed to come back as darth vader in
kenobi the cassian andor series
ahsoka and lando spin-offs rogue
squadron i'm gonna try to get to all of
it in the meantime be sure to subscribe
to new rock stars hit that notification
bell support us by checking out our
great merch options at
newarkstarsmerch.com follow me at eavos
following rockstars thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you